foreign
[Music]
the story of The Phantom of the Opera
has been told on the page stage and
screen for more than a hundred years it
centers around a shadowy figure who
performs haunting music in the Paris
Opera House long after audiences leave
it may not be quite as mysterious but
another accomplished musician is honing
her craft after hours at one of London's
most renowned venues Ian Lee paid her a
visit
there's magic after midnight at the
Royal Albert Hall
entering this Cathedral of music and in
its vast emptiness
among the rows of empty pews sits a
solitary figure
commanding the wind with the tips of her
fingers
[Music]
and Toes it's like this hidden world
that people don't even sort of know
exist while they're asleep in bed
Anna lapwood harnesses the power of the
organs
999 pipes performing to no one yet
everyone
to the side sits her phone
capturing each moment for social media
it's kind of like in the artificial Moon
Rising including unaware correspondence
Anna's Moonlight Mass
occurs when the organ is free but
playing it wasn't her first or even
second choice
my mom turned around to me one day when
I was a teenager and said have you ever
thought about taking up the organ
I said don't be ridiculous Mom it's the
worst instrument in the world I hate it
it's boring but I'm intimidated just
looking at this there's something about
total immersion that just you progress
so much faster and you fall in love with
it in a different way
what do you love about the workout
oh my gosh the whole building resonates
it shakes the foundations but before
Anna took off on social media
she became the youngest ever director of
Music at Pembroke College in Cambridge
her students turned this midnight
Maestro onto tick tock
how did you become so viral it happened
totally organically with this
collaboration with bonobo that happened
a couple of months into the residency
British musician bonobo heard her play
and a collaboration was born
electrifying fans and the music world I
feel like it's blown my musical world so
wide open I was suddenly there with 5
000 screaming fans screaming for the
organ which I've never had before what
did you feel in that moment oh my gosh
it was like ecstasy I could install as
mine and even now I get goosebumps just
thinking about it
[Music]
even Andrew Lloyd Webber took note it is
5 30 in the morning I'm in the Albert
Hall with one cleaner and I'm about to
scare the living daylight out of them by
playing Phantom of the Opera as loud as
I can
[Music]
so classical can be cool it can be cool
and it is it is cool breathing new life
and some coolness through these classic
pipes
for CBS Saturday morning Ian Lee London
[Music]
Royal Albert Hall I love it and whatever
it takes to make something that maybe
you wouldn't have thought was cool cool
is amazing I love Andrew Lloyd Webber's
reaction
with that poor cleaner though